(upbeat music)
- So Joe, I don't know if you know there's
I don't know, somewhere
around 7, 8, 9, 10 thousand
astrophysicists in the world,
and about, what are we up
to, 7, 8 billion people.
If you divide those two numbers,
an astrophysicist is one
in million in the world.
- Whoa.
- So if you're ever in
the same room with one,
that's when you need to
ask all the questions.
'Cause you just never know
the next chance that's coming.
So do you have any questions that
you've been harboring your whole life
about the universe that
you can ask right now?
- Yes, I do.
- What's that?
- Well I was thinking just before that,
I wonder if it's the
same amount as comedians.
Like professional comedians.
I bet it's really similar.
- Okay.
However, comedians as a practice
are always in front of many people.
- Yes.
- Being a comedian, you are
in front of tons of people.
Being a scientist, we're
never in front of anybody.
(chuckles)
So access to comedians
I think is much higher
than access to scientists,
to astrophysicists.
But those numbers could be the same.
- I bet they're pretty close.
So here's my question.
The concept of the multiverse,
the concept of alternative universes
with alternative laws of physics
is incredibly puzzling to me.
Now when you think about the idea
that this could be reality,
that there could be other universes
with different laws of physics,
there could be an infinite number
of these different laws of physics.
How does that work?
(Neil chuckles)
Okay, that's an excellent question.
We think, when I say we, just
the scientific community,
physicists who concern themselves
with the very early universe, cosmologist,
that the laws of physics
as we experience them,
are set in the very earliest
stages of the universe.
And quantum fluctuations, in everything,
would be responsible for another universe
having slightly different
laws of physics than ours.
Because the quantum fluctuations
will take it in a slightly different
law of physics direction
than our universe.
And this would just keep going.
Every universe that's born.
Even if it started out sort of the same
in the very first instant,
a later instant with other
laws of physics manifest
could be slightly different.
And with the multiverse
where there could be
pockets of the universe that are expanding
with no knowledge of any
other pockets of the universe.
These are essentially,
independent universes
from one another, and
never the twain will meet.
Imagine you're a ship at sea
and you look to the horizon,
and that's your whole universe
there, to the horizon.
There's another ship that
has it's own horizon,
and you declare this is the universe
and these ships don't
even see each other, okay?
You'll only see each other if somehow,
your two horizons can overlap.
And we don't know how to
do that in our universe
'cause they're noncausal.
You'd have to find some way to tunnel
from one universe to the
other in order to access that.
But that could be very dangerous
because if the laws of
physics are different
than the ones you evolved on,
then you could just
dissolve into a pile of goo
because the charge on the
electron is different,
and all of your biochemistry would change.
So the difference in laws of physics
comes about because of quantum physics
and, I'm gonna call it random,
it's random but predictable,
so in other words, you
can have a variation
in the properties of something,
and because of the quantum fluctuations
that exist within it.
And when that's happening
in the early universe,
you are quantum fluctuating
the laws of physics themselves.
And that's how you get one universe
with a slightly different laws
of physics than the other.
There could be a universe where,
the laws of physics there
will never allow matter to coalesce.
You'll never get stars.
That would be a lifeless universe.
As far as we can think.
There could be another universe
where you can make stars,
but you don't make heavy elements.
That would be a universe with stars
and beautiful night skies as we have now,
but nothing that we know and love.
No planets, no life.
Because our ingredients come
from the centers of stars that explode.
The manufacturers, the
whole periodic table
of elements, where does that come from?
Exploding stars, okay?
So you can imagine other universes
that are not our universe.
There could be universes
more cooler than ours.
Universes where they form life
way faster than ours did.
We didn't have enough
ingredients to make life
until we can make a planet.
Every time a star blows up
and it has these heavy elements,
it's not enough the first round.
You gotta accumulate them.
And we're like second or third generation
supernova here in our solar system.
And only then you get
enough to have oxygen,
carbon, nitrogen, silicon,
iron, we got enough.
We got a solid planet.
- So there's more than one supernova
has to take place before enough elements--
- More than one generations
of supernova, yeah.
You can add up how much that is,
and it's feeding the entire galaxy,
so yeah.
- Meaning a star
has to supernova, and then
a new star has to form
and then supernova--
- Correct, correct.
So you need a few of those generations
to get enough density of non-original
star material to make
things like whole balls
of planets, for example.
And even so, it's not very much material.
As big as Saturn and Jupiter are,
they're made of mostly--
- Gas.
- Mostly hydrogen and
helium that were made
in the big bang, not made in stars.
- Is it possible that
there's something else
that could be invented or created rather,
when more generations of supernovas occur
that hasn't happened yet?
Like it took so many
generations for planets
to--
- Very interesting.
So we are the product of the mixtures
of ingredients that are in this universe.
So if you rank the elements in your body,
the number one element is hydrogen,
contained in the water molecule.
'Cause we're mostly water
as you may remember from biology.
The next most common atom is oxygen.
From the water molecule.
Third most is carbon.
We're carbon based life.
Fourth most is nitrogen.
Well wait a minute, those are the top four
ingredients in the universe itself.
In order.
Sorry, not including helium
which is chemically inert.
You couldn't use it anyway.
So it's the top four chemically active
ingredients in the uni--
we're made of that!
So you ask a brilliant question.
Is there some other universe
that has a different
mixture of other ingredients
and they opportunistically
made stuff out of those other ingredients?
That's a great question.
I've never thought about that.
What would a universe be like
if it was mostly molybdenum?
(chuckles) or something.
Pick some elements.
Pick some random other
four set of elements
and see what you can come up with.
You need some chemical activity in it.
Carbon is highly reactive
with other elements,
so that's good.
It's not an accident
that we're carbon based.
We think other life
elsewhere in the universe
would be carbon based
'cause carbon is plentiful
and it bonds in so many different ways.
If you experimenting with
the diversity of life,
carbon is your element to do that on.
So this urge, let's see if
you have silicon based life.
Sure, 'cause silicon
sits right below carbon
on the periodic table.
It makes all the same kinds of molecules.
You've heard of carbon dioxide, CO2,
there's silicon dioxide, SiO2.
It makes the same families of molecules.
So you can, why not make life with,
sure, maybe, but there's
five times as much carbon
in the universe than silicon.
You don't have to appeal to silicon.
Carbon is there knocking on your door.
So for me, what's curious to me
is the assertion that
if we have a multiverse
and there's an infinite
number of universes,
that means there's an
infinite combinations
of all things that had
ever happened, ever,
that there's another pair of us
having this conversation
in another universe
except you're wearing a red shirt
and I'm wearing a whatever.
I mean, you make tiny changes in what is,
and say that's happening
in one other universe.
Somewhere.
And people are wondering, does
this give you immortality?
If you exist in this other universe,
is that really you?
If your entire molecular
structure's identical,
is that really you?
And I think people are overstepping there.
I don't think it's really you.
It's a copy of you, but it's not you.
And my evidence for that
is if you're a twin,
you don't wake up as your twin, ever.
Even though you're molecularly identical
to each other from birth.
You don't share each other's conscious.
So one of you is an exact
replica of the other,
except you're not the same human beings.
So I can make an exact
replica of you somewhere else,
but I don't think you'll
know or care or feel it.
So this talk of "I will live forever,"
even when you upload your consciousness.
We don't understand
consciousness enough to know
what makes you you and me me.
Why do I wake up as me
everyday, and not as you?
Or as anybody else?
That's consciousness.
Can that be carbon copied
(chuckles) carbon copied.
Can that be duplicated
and put somewhere else
and that still be you?
Or are you just making a twin?
There's a whole other
independent consciousness.
That's what keeps me up at night.
This concept of different laws of physics
is all from the quantum.
- I think it's gonna
keep me up at night, too.
(Neil laughs)
- Thanks Joe,
- Thank you.
- for your question.
- My pleasure.
- This has been Star Talk.
A one on one with the
one and only Joe Rogan,
wrestling, MMAing his deepest
questions in the cosmos.
(Joe laughs)
(upbeat music)